coup de projecteur sur un tourangeau
atypique instituteur le jour artiste
toujours les images sont signés fabienne
marcel créateur bricoleur inventeur et
riz est un artiste autodidacte il crée
d'improbables machines et des objets
improbables et reese se disculpe intra-
ou encore plasticisme j'adore ce genre
de pied y est inique et charnelle parce
que voyez par exemple celui ci on va
bien une belle paire de fesses et c'est
pas formidables à prendre son pied avec
des fesses un décapeur thermique en
guise de pinceau l'artiste apprécié les
matériaux pauvres comme le plastique et
riz ne se raconte pas il fait raconter
une histoire à ses créations
le bonheur c'est pas de tous de
rencontrer l'autre c'est de chercher
l'autre c'est le cheminement
c'est à la fois de la sculpture et de la
peinture et il met en fait je suis pas
un vrai pas ce culte heures ni un vrai
peintes et je trouve que par contre je
peux être un vrai d2 et riz est un
humaniste dans aquatique par exemple ils
tentent d'améliorer le monde et tout en
bas il ya des poissons complètement
difformes et c'est un monde inexploré
mais il ya aussi des détritus ce avec
des bouées simplement pour dire que sur
chaque détritus ce il devrait avoir des
bouées sur chaque d'écriture dans la mer
pour les faire remonter à la surface
notamment il ya des déchets nucléaires
qu'on balance dans la mer incognito
à
moi j'adore jouer au large j'adore jouer
et pour mal à la sculpture ça doit être
aussi un jeu eduardo lourdement même
pour traiter de la mort il faut mettre
de la couleur merde mais de l'humour
qu'on découvre une fois qu entre
guillemets qu'on a réfléchi pas de
l'humour facile pour donner le plaisir
aux visiteurs d'avoir la satisfaction
d'avoir découvert fantaisie féerie
l'artiste sait bien que l'humour
facilite l'accès à l'art se plie là il
vaut 50 euros celui-ci il vaut 51 euros
pourquoi et bien tout simplement pas
celui ci c'est pied gauche voyez et le
pgo si la marche est là
je
un peu de pop garage optiques et haute
en machine avec emily thorne en elle son
groupe forever pas vote
c'est ce soir
traces d'exil ou le parcours d'un
expatrié hongrois dans le style engagé
des documentaires naturaliste nicolas
muller photographie aussi bien les
enfants des rues que les ouvriers au
total ce sont plus d'une centaine de
clichés de porto à casarès
ancien membre de massive attack et
pilier du trip hop londonien tri qui
sera de passage à l'astrolabe mercredi
cap au sud la semaine prochaine nous
irons à l'arboretum d'argenton sur
creuse à la rencontre de geoffroy grosse